one of the best lines in wakanda Forever
wasn't even in the script here's the
story behind the improvised moment fans
can't get enough of spoilers ahead the
sequel to one of Marvel's most
successful movies black panther wakanda
forever is already setting records of
its own having broken records for a
November opening set in the wake of King
t'challa's death which mirrors the
real-life death of his actor Chadwick
Boseman the movie explores how that loss
affects those who are closest to the
late Monarch that means wakanda forever
functions a lot like an ensemble film
despite its Central character Arc
belonging to shuri for instance actor
Winston Duke gets a lot more screen time
as in Baku ruler of the mountain
dwelling Jabari tribe mbaku's role is
much expanded in wakanda Forever
compared to the first black panther
where he's become much more connected to
the rest of wakanda even holding
sessions with the Kingdom's elders but
while umbaku may have softened a bit
he's still the intimidating wall of
muscle fans know and love though his
gruffness belies kindness and humor
underneath it's still a lot of fun to
watch mbaku towering over everyone
around him and throwing his weight
around some of the most memorable lines
in the film belong to him you could even
call him a scene stealer I bet you could
but no in fact Duke came up with a few
of those lines himself the actor took to
Twitter to reveal at least one fan
favorite line that wasn't in the script
in a post on Twitter Duke revealed that
the moment when umbaku using a carrot as
a pointer calls Okoye a bald-headed
demon was in fact improvised as duke
explained part of his role in wakanda
Forever was to act as comic relief
intense situations and that aspect of
the role led him to come up with some of
umbaku's dialogue Duke wrote in his
tweet the intention for embaku in this
film is to serve as the vent for a
pressure cooker and that's what
influenced this improvisational gem
amongst others it's true that mbaku's
role in the film goes a long way to
Defuse The Heavy atmosphere hanging over
the proceedings few other characters in
wakanda Forever are afforded many
opportunities to express their comedic
side so mbaku's funniest lines helped to
balance out the movie's darker tones
even if the character isn't where he's
being humorous Duke sure is but Duke's
tweet implies that other umbaku dialogue
across the film was also his own
improvisational deviation from the
script thus raising the question which
other lines did Duke come up with that
mystery is sure to prompt at least some
fans to pay extra attention to umbaku's
Dialogue on a second viewing fans of
wakanda forever were excited to learn
that Winston Duke improvised his
bald-headed demon line from the film in
response to the actor's tweet revealing
that bit of behind the scenes lore his
replies were filled with fans who
expressed how much they had loved his
performance and that line in particular
one fan posted this was improvised
absolutely hilarious others were even
more hyperbolic with another fan
receiving hundreds of likes for posting
it's the single funniest line in MCU
history I can't imagine anyone was able
to keep a straight face the first time
you said it wakanda forever won't be the
last and sea of mbaku the end of the
film implies that he will take over as
the new king of wakanda at least for the
time being whenever the MCU returns to
wakanda mbaku is Almost sure to be there
[Music]